you're watching the press preview then
as we head into a new week we can look
at what is on the front pages uh tonight
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the economics correspondent at the
spectator kate andrews
and the new statement statesman's
political editor
stephen bush a very good evening to both
of you chatted to them in a moment first
of all let's take a look at some of the
front pages then starting with the metro
leading with two milestones in britain's
fight against kovid 19 with 30 million
people
having had their first vaccine and
family friends in
england able to meet outdoors all from
tomorrow
the telegraph reports that the term bame
should no longer be used by
organizations and companies
according to a report from boris
johnson's racial disparities commission
the guardian speaks with the leader of
britain's police chiefs
who has said the forces legitimacy in
black communities
is so low and vows to end generations of
stained
strained trust and confidence
onto the times leading with one of the
country's most senior police officers
who believe
schools have covered up sexual offences
in the past to protect their reputations
here's monday's ft which says britain's
third biggest steel producer gfg
alliance is scrambling to raise funds
for loans outside the uk
to prevent financial collapse the daily
mirror looks further into claims made by
american businesswoman jennifer r curie
concerning her relationship
with prime minister boris johnson
and i'm joined tonight by kate andrews
and stephen bush
great to see you both thanks for being
with us on the eve of easing
of lockdown restrictions finally feels
like it's taken forever
kate doesn't it and the front of the
metro uh jabby
monday not the greatest headline but
uh certainly a good news story i think
as long as things go according to plan
well yes indeed uh one of the reasons it
feels like it's taking so long is
because it
is this is set to be the longest
lockdown that england has
had so far um by a matter of months
really
tomorrow will be when we have more
freedoms to be outside um in a group up
to six people or
uh two different households which can be
up uh to more than six people but only
from two different households
and of course crucially that
stay-at-home messaging changes so you
don't
have to have a reasonable excuse to
leave your home any longer you can be
out and about enjoying yourself outside
um of course with that
cap of people on it and the government
has taken the most cautious approach to
leaving lockdown of course the major
difference between
the other times and this time is that we
now have a very successful vaccine
rollout and that is what the front page
of the metro is highlighting
we've now hit another milestone with 30
million people
having had at least their first
injection very recently we got to half
of the adult
population and and by the spectators
data tracker it looks like
like we could be hitting that milestone
of all the over 50s and most vulnerable
people jabbed
earlier than the 15th of april which is
the government's deadline but
potentially the beginning of april
if we can keep up the pace so there is a
lot of good news here
um but as you mentioned jonathan it is
taking quite a bit of time and of course
people are growing more and more
restless um outdoor activity is
certainly welcome
but we are still months away from being
able to get back to something that feels
like normal
yeah i mean just um on that kate do you
think it's too cautious do you think the
government
could have sped things up a bit uh i
think if you're going to say data not
dates you really have to commit to that
and the data has been so overwhelmingly
positive
unsurprisingly vaccines work and already
we're seeing that vaccine factor
in the data and of course we've known
for a very long time now that outdoor
activity in particular
has a very very low risk of transmitting
the virus
so unfortunately i don't think we always
have been following the data and the
scientific evidence i think if we were
it actually could certainly be leading
to a faster reopening
okay let's look at the front of the
guardian stephen warning to england as
lockdown
is east i mean this is the big fear
isn't it that people will push things
too far i mean even today i was taking
the dogs out for a walk and saw people
playing golf
uh on a on a local golf course already
um i mean do you think people will stick
to
the guidelines or do you think people
are going to see this as a sort of
chance to
get away with all sorts especially if
they've had the jab
well i think it with any law of
regulation there's always some law
breaking at the margin
i think kate's exactly right then one
problem we've created for ourselves
because the understanding of
the risks of the chronovirus it has not
been as as
wise foreign would like and it doesn't
seem to have informed government policy
some of the time
i ultimately those people playing golf
have more chance of becoming the first
british people to be killed by a falling
satellite than they do of catching
covered outside
so i think we can to be honest live with
a little bit of of law breaking outside
i think the risk is if people don't
understand that
do they think well we're allowed to meet
outside we're taking a risk anyway
might as well uh gather indoors a much
riskier activity until people have got
their
their jab and the whole and we and we've
all got our jabs
that i think is the risk but i think to
be honest uh all the evidence is british
people have followed the rules the vast
majority of them at least and i don't
see
any reason to believe that that will
change and stephen i mean the other good
news today the modena jabs are on the
way
yeah and this is the fantastic thing
right then as well as the addition
of the existing vaccines which not only
work but we've had a pretty good stress
test and they work
here in israel we have another set of
vaccines that have also been approved
also shown to be very effective coming
on stream so the uh the era in which we
will all have uh well i say we'll all
have matching ones to go with our tb
jabs and i remember the internet people
in
in big cities who have their tb jabs but
i'll have my matching jab very soon and
then hopefully we'll all be able to do
things like this in person again
let's move on to the daily telegraph uh
great picture
of uh two people in the swimming pool
there outdoor swimming pool then if you
can see that uh front page of the
telegraph
um i mean how tempting that looks can't
wait to uh to plunge into a pool
once again um but uh the story they're
focusing on is jab
checks maybe last straw for pubs um
kate uh and we know this is uh a real
concern
for republicans um and uh writing for
the daily telegraph the
the boss of weatherspoons never short of
a comment or two
no tim martin isn't um so the
telegraph's headline is prompted because
tim martin has written for the paper
today
uh suggesting that a vaccine passport
scheme could just be detrimental
um as pubs tried to reopen and this is a
debate that's going to be playing out we
know that these
ideas are under review right now and we
have gone a long way in a very short
period of time
from the health secretary saying that
this is not a paper where you this is
not country apologies it's not a country
where you carry papers
um the vaccine minister nadeem zawahi
suggesting that they were not
considering vaccine or immunity
passports
and now they're all anybody can talk
about and and the prime minister has
confirmed that they are considering them
as a way to reopen potentially full
capacity uh when we're allowed to do so
i think they're going to be
a lot of hurdles here but the major
question that i think a lot of these
owners of pubs and restaurants will have
is to what extent will this really be
voluntary
it's one thing to say you as as a
private landowner get to choose who
comes in and out of your premises
but it's quite another to say you
technically have the choice but if you
don't require
checks at the door you don't require
people to show their vaccine papers or
their negative cova test
you can only open at 60 or 75 capacity
that is essentially making it mandatory
because it'll be very hard
to make a profit with that kind of
capacity so a lot is riding on these
reviews
everyone's been focused on the road map
but really some of those crucial
questions
around social distancing and how we can
actually go back to normal
have yet to come they've saved the
hardest decision for the reviews that
are being
undertaken now yeah and of course steven
it's not just pubs is it it's going to
be
sporting events potentially outdoor
gatherings festivals
where do you stand on the debate
well i think one it would be quite
troubling for us to move towards having
quite
the an extensive level of biosecurity
and biosurveillance as a society
society i don't think that's desirable
but i also think um
i don't often find myself sliding with
tim martin but there's a first time for
everything here
we've asked hospitality to bear an awful
lot of costs over the last year
yes they've received subsidy for
salaries and for rent but they're fixed
costs goods that they've ordered in the
open again closed again
off and on right these businesses have a
lot of debt and a lot of losses as they
come out of the pandemic it is not
reasonable if the government is going to
require this
whether they do that de facto or de jure
is not reasonable to make hospitality
pay for it in terms of the additional
costs of enforcing it
not least because many of them simply
won't be able to and they already face a
very difficult
um second half of 2021. yeah and i
suppose stephen you know that the
republicans and
and uh large hospitality venues are
going to say well look we've already
spent a fortune
making our premises covid safe and now
you're asking us to spend even more
money potentially
yeah and the additional problem is a lot
of the things people are asked to do to
make their businesses
covered safe no more make you covered
safe than if we sort of put i don't know
like a rosary and some salt in the
corner right
yeah those perspex walls don't do very
much
and businesses have been asked to come
up with those costs up front themselves
so
i think it is very reasonable for
businesses to turn around and go look if
we're going to have to do this
yo richie you've got to put your own
hand in your pocket mate okay
kate let's move on to the financial
times the prime minister obviously
focusing on
the positives especially tomorrow with
us all getting some
form of freedom back but there are many
negatives as well
john lewis has really struggled hasn't
it during this pandemic
and it's now going to set store by
waitrose to try and uh
help the company i think steven hit a
lot of the
economic analysis on the head there and
the struggle that this has been
and but this story is highlighting the
ways that um consumer behavior have just
massively changed very much been
accelerated really those changes
um during the kovac crisis and now many
of these big shops are asking themselves
do we need these in-person premises do
we need these big shops
to actually uh make good for what the
customers want us to
deliver and john lewis is going to be
looking to waitrose
and they've done a detailed analysis of
more than 20 million
customers across their departments and
what they're finding
is that they can keep some of those
really big shops they do find that
people are driven to them
but some of the smaller outlets they're
more likely to close down
and this has very big implications
especially for the labor market for
people who are
working in retail questions around their
jobs and it's one of the reasons we are
pretty sure
that unemployment is going to continue
to take up even as the economy
reopens because unfortunately we're
going to discover that a lot of those
millions of people on furlough hopefully
not that many but potentially millions
of people on furlough
don't have jobs to go back to nobody
knows exactly what that number will be
the good news is that it's being revised
downwards and the comeback of a strong
economy
is thought to help the labor market but
in reality there's going to be some
major change it's going to happen quite
quickly
yeah so many unknowns stephen arnold it
does feel that the last year is almost
accelerated things when it comes to
retail and when it comes to the high
street
yeah and that acceleration is the
crucial point we all where we've all
known we've been
talking on programmers for years about
the decline of the high street
the move to online retailers of course
the difficulty is
what may have happened this year is that
process has happened too quickly for
businesses to adapt and this will result
in more job losses than that process
we would have expected to see at a
faster rate than new jobs are created
and it's particularly difficult not just
for john lewis so yeah they'll become
they'll
certainly be fine you know the beloved
brand but um if you think about say
birmingham new street
which has a beautiful big john lewis and
it's very very nice redesigned it's
really the jewel of that that
development
what does the absence of john lewis mean
for that station for the surrounding
areas
the high streets around the united
kingdom have lost uh their john lewises
which really are sort of anchor
institutions for those high streets
potentially it's going to be a very
painful um transition and a very
difficult
three to four years as a result
particularly of course if distanced
working mate
remains a big feature of how we live and
work very quickly i'm going to ask you
both uh what are you most looking
forward to
tomorrow kate i'm not sure i'm going to
be doing it tomorrow
um i'll be at work but i am looking
forward to sitting in a park
with a few friends um and having a drink
steven
well i'm actually on holiday from
tomorrow so i will be uh in my local
park
working on my tan um so i'm very much
looking forward to that
well the weather is going to be great
apparently next few days thank you both
very much
speak after the break because coming up
the clocks have gone forward by an hour
but it takes a whole day for
parliament's 2 000 clocks to catch up
we'll look at that story
in the metro
welcome back part two of the press
preview economics correspondent at the
spectator kate andrews and the new
statesman's political editor stephen
bush both still
with me stephen let's get cracking front
page of the daily telegraph now this is
interesting scrap use of
b.a.m.e label according to an
independent
report uh the acronym is outdated what
are your thoughts
um well i mean this is an interesting
story of true i mean
the government does actually or already
doesn't use this and they have a
pretty useful explanation on the cabinet
office website as to why because
the average person from a black asian or
mine or other minority ethnic ground
doesn't understand what the word bain
means and the ones who do understand it
mostly don't think it's a particularly
um a particularly useful term because it
lumps in a whole variety of people
and lots of people don't really
understand like am are they go does this
include me did not include me
um so that i think is not that
surprising i think it's um
it does raise the question about this
commission which is is it going to
add anything all that new then theresa
may is actually a pretty good
um disparity audit um which looked at
all of the inequalities across race
class
um gender place it was a really good bit
of work yeah whether or not this
commission is really going to
add anything and you know if if this
recommendation is is
is a sign of what's in it the answer to
that is going to be no but it's a very
sensible uh recommendation there is a
reason why the government doesn't
doesn't use it it
doesn't mean anything to most people
kate
yeah as steven says um this is already
um
made very clear on the government's
website the reasons that they aren't
using this term i suppose you could say
that the independent commission might be
raising it because
um it has become a very mainstream term
and many organizations outside of
government do use it and it's constantly
used in daily discourse especially in
the media so
perhaps they're trying to highlight that
and for good reason trying to highlight
that it's not a good idea
to try to lump everybody together when
they're you know very individualistic or
specific circumstances for
different ethnic minority groups um and
also as stephen says it's a term that
doesn't resonate with a lot of people
either because they don't identify that
way or they don't understand it
so it might be the highlighting element
might be quite good but
i think steven's quite quite right to
point out that actually has been
highlighted for quite some time on an
official government website okay
all right and on to the metro um this
debate's been going on for some days now
hasn't it about badly grammar school
and the whole debate about whether we
should ban things
because it offends people of one
religion stephen
yeah i mean i think in some ways right
the
should we ban things part this is not
actually a particularly interesting or
useful
uh debate right that's what this letter
right later writer is taking
uh offense to and it's what the the
latest in the story which is people
calling explicitly
four lessons like that to be banned um
now i think ultimately you can come up
with a if you can come up with a
pedagogy rationale so a good teaching
rationale to go
you know here's why teenagers not only
need to be told that a cartoon of
muhammad is offensive
to practicing muslims but to be shown a
cartoon now
i don't think that should be banned but
i don't think it necessarily reflects
very well in a school if you think that
some teenagers need to be shown a
cartoon to understand what a cartoon is
but i think one of the problems we have
with this story is we're still missing
one of the crucial bits of
information which is what was the actual
content of this class i think we can all
agree that it should be
should not be prohibited to uh to yeah
to
display a cartoon of the prophet
muhammad if that's your bag
what we don't yet know is whether or not
what actually happened
in this classroom yeah exactly um kate
we haven't got time for your thoughts on
that because i just want to squeeze this
picture in we've only got 20 seconds
rather appropriately
time flies when you're changing 2 000
clocks a great picture there
of the speaker of the house helping to
put them all forward by
now yeah we've all probably gone around
our homes today and updated the
various clocks um but uh that has been
on overdrive
uh in parliament where the speaker of
the house has had to do this not
personally but had to instruct to make
sure it's done
to over 2 000 clocks to make sure that
mps are on time now they don't have any
excuse
what i want to know is how many were
using that as an excuse in the first
place to show up late to work
i think that's the outstanding question
in this story great speaking clock would
have been a better headline i think
kate stephen thank you both very much